and so actually what's your issue here
well today the FDA has come out with
some proposed changes to the listing
rules which would essentially weaken
some of the protections for shareholders
we think this is bad for London and it
risks undoing a lot of the progress
we've made around strong corporate
governance proposals which we think make
gives London its good reputation for
good strong shareholder protections so
the FCA is proposing that we create a
new category called companies that are
controlled by a sovereign entity I mean
they're clearly drawn the distinction
here with some of the corporate
governance disasters we've had in the
past where a family-owned oligarch have
been running it why is that not enough
fede thing well this is a concern I mean
clearly the city has a very short memory
I mean it was only four or five years
ago where we had companies like Iain RC
listing in London and and that was a
disaster for shareholders so the concern
is these rules are there for a purpose
for a reason and it's to protect the
interest of minority shareholders and
the FCA is proposing at the moment to
sort of undo some of those protections
which is a big concern but is the north
should there not be recognition that a
sovereign entity like the Kingdom of
Saudi Arabia is probably a more
responsible shareholder than the people
who were behind enr see they just
referred to well I think we're not
making a judgment call on who's
responsible who's not responsible the
issue is are the governance standards in
place to protect the shareholders it
doesn't matter who who ultimately is the
shareholder it's about the minorities
and the control that they can exercise
at the company this is a really tricky
one though isn't it because obviously
post brexit Britain wants to show itself
to be open for business around the world
attracting Saudi Aramco to the London
Stock Exchange would be a pretty big
achievement wouldn't it certainly and we
think it's really important that we
track capital to London and we need to
ask ourselves what type of capital do we
want to attract so we've got governments
like Japan who have put in really strong
corporate governance standards in order
to attract capital because they think
ultimately that good governance
standards means it's good for
performance it's good for the business
good for the market and we think that
this is potentially eroding some of the
governance standard we set up in London
and it is really a slippery slope do you
think the financial conduct authority is
bowing to commercial pressures here well
currently it's out for consultation
so certainly ourselves and some of our
other colleagues will be giving feedback
to the FDA that we don't think the rule
changes are pro
and so hopefully ultimately we come out
with the best decisions in the best
regulation for the market sooner
nutshell as far as you're concerned on
these terms London market is better off
without Saudi Aramco I believe well I
think the issue is really what kind of
companies are trying to attract so maybe
companies like Saudi Aramco but there
might be other companies that are
looking to list here and essentially we
want to make sure any company coming to
list here we welcome the capital but you
need to have you need to have high
standards you need to play by the rules
alright Ashley Hamilton Classen from
Roland an asset management it's good to
see things that are taking us through
that